mizzou so omixlogic
is a training program developed by
pine biotech which has been started as a
technology transfer company
from the university of haifa from the
tower bioinformatics research center
there at the center the team is focused
on developing
novel algorithmic approaches to
multi-omics data integration
and we have a team that works on
translating that research platform
to practical use in many different areas
of
molecular medicine uh genomics
transcriptomics
metagenomics and other types of ominous
data but as a result of this
we have developed a program that is now
being used by
thousands of people from around the
world and multiple universities and as a
result we have trained
a number of students and researchers to
utilize some of the resources to
elevate their level of bioinformatics
and provide with excellent support to
use big data
in various areas of research so
omixlogic
is essentially a program that provides
training in bioinformatics
that enables independent research that
is guided by mentors and pure example
and we are developing a growing
community with shared passion for data
driven research and
appreciation of citizen science so not
only
researchers that are already doing
research but also those that are
interested to do that
and are interested to do that even
without a deep expertise that they
already possess
and our goal is to enable students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research
using the latest technology in life in
data science
and so what we've realized over the
course of these programs
is that data science plays a central
role
in the ability to extract meaningful
insights
from biomedical and biological data
and as a result we identified the need
to provide
training in statistical analysis and
machine learning
design of experiments how to
properly design them to get the right
kind of information
including elimination of technical
variation and provide
tools and skills in data mining for
meaningful
patterns and associations between
phenotype and genotype at multiple omics
levels
and to study complex biological systems
using big data so the goal of this data
science program
is to really introduce the participants
to various types of omics data
including different technical formats
and data types
and file formats and what are the
specific
challenges to translate those raw data
formats to structured
data formats to learn about exploratory
data analysis and the steps of
processing data in preparation for
downstream analysis so how to
actually use the information that is
structured and prepared and what kinds
of considerations we should have
before we start the analysis itself
introduce the participants to big data
analysis tools for large-scale
project data and to try different
methods of machine learning
in r and python and then to learn
the important links between data and
biology so how to
interpret the found patterns linking the
methods that were used
to analyze the data with biologically
meaningful insights
who is this program for so the program
is
really for anyone with an interest
in biological data and specifically in
all mixed data including students from
high school
colleges universities but also for
biologists and clinicians that have
some kind of research work that is
probably acquiring
more and more uh characteristics of a
data science project and what is a data
science project essentially
a data science project is a project
that requires in-depth understanding of
data how it was generated what does it
represent
what is the context of the project
itself it also requires to wrangle
and process that data so oftentimes
we start from a dump of data
whether it is raw sequencing reads
or all kinds of notes about something so
it's really
unorganized information and the
final part of it is that there's a
challenge and the challenge
is to work through all of this mess
and translate that into something
meaningful meaningful can mean
visualization so that the visualization
visually the data is summarized in the
proper way
uh it could also mean that we are going
to take
some biological experiment that can be
viewed through multiple different
perspectives and we need to understand
what do all of these perspectives mean
and that means data
integration and also it can mean
we can train some kind of a machine
learning model to
help us understand what happens
in a new data set based on a data set
we've already explored so
we'll talk about all of these components
but i think that all of them are
relevant
for students that are learning about
this or for
practitioners those that are already
using
this kind of data in their